[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ses sens
public votre rendez vous quotidien de
débats de reportages et des analyses sur
public sénat avec nos experts on vous
propose de donner du sens à l'actualité
à 18h à 22h du lundi au jeudi et voici
le sommaire de ce 14 septembre comment
mieux encadrer la chasse comment
partager la nature entre chasseurs et
promeneurs c'est l'objectif du rapport
sénatorial remis aujourd'hui
interdiction de l'alcool et des
stupéfiants formation renforcée
certificat médical annuel mais pas de
jour sans chasse c'était pourtant l'une
des principales revendications des 122
mille signataires de la pétition à
l'origine de ce rapport ça nous promet
un débat passionnant dans une minute
c'est l'une des polémiques de l'été un
jeu organisé au centre pénitentiaire de
fresnes avec notamment une course de
kart une polémique hypocrite alors que
le vrai scandale c'est l'état lamentable
de nos prisons voilà ce que dit la
contrôleuse des lieux de privation de
liberté qui participera à notre second
débat tout à l'heure à quoi sert la
prison comment lutter contre la
surpopulation carcérale le gouvernement
construite il suffisamment de nouvelles
maisons d'arrêt beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
donc ce rapport du sénat sur la chasse
il est résumé par jonathan des prières
mieux encadrer la chasse pour limiter
les accidents voilà l'objectif du
rapport du sénat publié aujourd'hui à
l'issue de plusieurs mois d'auditions et
de déplacements de terrain en résulte 30
propositions dont certaines risquent de
faire couler beaucoup d'encre y compris
du côté des pro chasse les sénateurs
plaide par exemple pour renforcer
l'examen du permis de chasser ils
réclament aussi une formation théorique
et pratique pour posséder une carabine
les parlementaires veulent aussi rendre
obligatoire l'obtention d'un certificat
médical chaque année pour chasser les
sénateurs préconisent aussi d'interdire
l'usagé de stupéfiants et de l'alcool
lors des parties de chasse en s'alignant
sur le code de la route avoir quelqu'un
qui a un fusil dans les mains et qui en
état d'ébriété ça pose quand même
question
aujourd'hui la réglementation fait que
bah rien ne l'interdît quelqu'un qui est
sur ses terres
avec un petit verre dans le nez qui
porte son arme personne ne peut rien
faire personne ne peut rien lui dire je
crois que il ya une correction à faire
mais certains points du rapport ont
provoqué la colère des écologistes
notamment l'absence de jours sans chasse
au niveau national et c'est surtout la
20e proposition consacrant la création
d'un délit d' entrave à l'achat ce qui a
fait bondir certains sénateurs comme
daniel salmon cette proposition numéro
20 fait un petit peu tâche pour moi dans
ce rapport parce que l aileron un peu le
postulat de départ qui disait ce n'est
pas un rapport ce pour ou contre la
chasse c'est un rapport sur la sécurité
et là on arrive sur je t'entends bien je
vois bien comment ça s'est passé c'est
une c'est une préconisation d' équilibre
pour faire passer pas mal de choses qui
sont fortes pour les faire passer auprès
des chasseurs donc on a mis cette
préconisation enfin patrick chaize la
mise je pense que et elle n'a rien à
faire là et que il faut l'enlever c'est
une atteinte aux libertés quelque part
d'autres mesures figurent dans le
rapport notamment sur le suivi des armes
en circulation ou sur la compétence des
policiers municipaux en matière de
chasse ces travaux pourraient donner
lieu à une proposition de loi
prochainement
voilà notre débat sur la charge les
transparents avec vous il ya certains de
nos invités qui sont entre la gare
montparnasse et et le sénat qui vont
arriver d'autres qu'on est en train
d'essayer de joindre par skype en
visioconférence mais heureusement hélène
barbry la bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
porte parole des associations de défense
des victimes de la chasse et d'animaux
ça regroupe plusieurs
collectifs notamment le collectif un
jour un chasseur rue ou en colère enfin
je vais pas citer toutes les
associations mais à l'origine de cette
pétition qui a reçu 122 mille signatures
et qui a donc provoqué notamment ce
rapport du sénat avec nous également en
visioconférence en duplex tancrède de la
morinerie bonsoir bienvenue merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes directeur des rédactions de riz
world media et donc
magazine le chasseur français matthieu
croissandeau est à mes côtés évidemment
éditorialiste politique bonsoir mathieu
peut-être une action un peu générale
hélène barbry on vient de résumer dans
notre sujet les propositions va dire les
plus importantes de ce rapport bon on en
a parlé un petit peu avant vous êtes
déçu c'est clair oui on est déçu alors
juste pour préciser je parle au nom du
collectif un jour un chasseur à bien des
opposants à la chasse animal cross ça se
passe ça va la fondation brigitte bardot
la lfb à la lp o one voice track ruraux
en colère et stéphane lamart ça montre
quand même qu'on est nombreux à être
sensibles à ce dossier quand on a lu le
rapport on a été extrêmement déçu il ne
faut pas oublier que la pétition elle
part d'une victime morgan pour rappeler
les faits qui avaient 25 ans qui
taillait du bois dans son jardin avec un
casque orange fluo sur les oreilles et
qui a été abattu d'une balle en plein
thorax par un chasseur qui l'a pris pour
un sanglier donc cette pétition elles
viennent de la douleur de proches et au
final on aboutit à un rapport qui
dépénalise qui proposent de dépénaliser
des infractions qui propose des disques
des déductions fiscales pour les
chasseurs et on n'est pas du tout dans
ce qu avait ce qu'on avait demandé
je me tourne vers vous tancrède de la
morinerie j'imagine que vous avez pris
connaissance des de ses 30 propositions
on a le sentiment
que quand même le lobby des chasseurs a
pesé beaucoup plus que celui des non
chasseurs avant la rédaction de ce
rapport et vous
en fait j'ai pas tout à fait la même
vision que moi j'ai surtout l'impression
que ni les chasseurs ni les personnes
qui ont signé
des associations peuvent présente madame
sont satisfaits du rapport d'une
certaine façon je dirais que du coup le
politique a peut-être bien fait son
travail parce que si les uns ni les
autres sont totalement satisfait ça veut
dire qu'ils ont fait peut-être preuve
d'indépendance
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont quand même
écouté beaucoup de monde
voilà c'est un rapport c'est à dire
qu'ils font des préconisations alors ça
peut peut-être pas satisfaire tout le
monde en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet je trouve qu'ils sont en part
en ayant un certain nombre de
propositions qui peuvent peut-être
plaire ou nombreux chasseurs ou 12 ans
qui sont opposés à la chasse mais en
tout cas ça permet au moins d'avoir une
base pour pouvoir regarder ces questions
et aux effectives mans plus de 170
audition ici au sénat donc ça a été un
travail de fond qui a été réalisée je
reste avec vous tant que de la morinerie
qu'est ce qui pour vous peut déplaire
aux chasseurs dans ce rapport
je pense que ça il peut avoir un certain
nombre de contraintes et mise en place
de choses qui peuvent effectivement
déplaire ou en tout cas voilà les
chasseurs pour trouver ça assez
contraignant en revanche le rapport
montre qu'il ya une très forte baisse
depuis 20 ans des accidents de chasse et
ça vraiment moi qui m'ont permis de
chasse tous horizons et du chasseur je
m'en réjouis parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des victimes c'est un drame
et les chasseurs sont les premiers
choqué faut le dire c'est ça aussi donc
moi je trouve ça bien que nier c'est
très forte baisse des accidents de
chasse et ça va continuer parce qu'il
faut aller un matin à une chasse en
battue entre sangliers pour voir comment
sont répétés à chaque fois les consignes
et comme comment tous les chefs de
l'hymne est responsable de chasse sont
impliqués donc c'est rentré depuis
longtemps dans les moeurs et maintenant
je pense que les chasseurs sont
extrêmement prudents donc ça je à
nouveau on va encore insisté sur ces
choses là et tant mieux quoi alors je
vous donne la parole sur sur ces
chiffres et sur la baisse des accidents
matthew intervenir moi je suis pas du
tout un spécialiste de la chasse mais
j'ai lu ce rapport comme comme un
béotien qui découvrent et je trouve que
ça dresse un constat des pratiques
actuelles en creux qui me paraît assez
désarçonnant si j'ose dire je prends
quatre propositions la numéro 4
renforcer l'examen du permis de chasser
en rendant obligatoire la maîtrise des
armes semi automatiques et on sait qu'il
y en a quand même quelques unes et une
épreuve de performance au tir donc déjà
on peut chasser sans son sens forcément
être performant au tir chossat quand
même assez dangereux rendre le
certificat médical obligatoire comme
pour tous les autres sports d'armes
c'est là car nous est lynché cameron
c'est bon on en a convenu et le gris
enfants mais à noël c'est sinon voilà on
peut être n'importe quel état de santé
on peut avoir la maladie de parkinson et
continue à chasser comme ça pendant
pendant des années interdire l'alcool l
usage de stupéfiants lors de la chasse
mais où on en est je vais ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut on entendre dans
le reportage tout à l'heure chasser
alors qu'on alors qu'on est bourré jeu
développé une culture du tir bas en
espère au moins que on a développé une
culture du tir et je vous donne la
dernière sur la sécurité qui m'a
profondément choqué je me demande où ces
gens vivre alors graduée la suspension
ou le retrait du permis de chasser en
fonction de la gravité de l'infraction
en clair en cas d'homicide partir direct
le retrait du permis pourrait être
systématique et l'interdiction de
repasser porter à 10 ans autrement dit
quand vous avez un chasseur qui tue
quelqu'un partir direct le ce la
suspension du permis n'est pas
automatique aujourd'hui les là les
sénateurs recommandent qu'elle pourrait
être systématique et qu'on pourrait lui
interdire de repasser le permis pendant
dix ans enfin dans quel monde on vit
tanqueray de la morinerie est ce que
vous voyez là sûrement d'écrans de
contrôle un peu un taux réagir
c'est moi j'ai eu un peu le même
sentiment en lisant le rapport cet après
midi alors peut-être que nous on est des
des urbains
hors sol jeudi soir en autriche à
saint-just non cadrée mais on se dit bon
roman ça n'a pas été fait avant quoi
en fait c'est c'est eh bien moi même de
mes connaissances sur la chasse et
l'examen du permis de chasse il faut
savoir que le permis de chasse vous avez
deux examens vous avez un examen
théorique un examen pratique l'examen
pratique vous avez pendant une journée
vous êtes devant des inspecteurs de
l'office français de la diversité vous
leur montrez comment vous maniez l'âme
si à un moment vous avez un geste qui
peut porter à confusion sur la façon
dont vous maniéré sais pas vous êtes
éliminés donc ça veut dire que comme
monsieur votre journée que je trouve
d'ailleurs très sympathique 1 je rêve de
l'emmener à la chasse pour lui faire
découvrir à quoi sert ça correspond
vraiment en fait on est habitué à manier
des armes depuis notre plus tendre
enfance depuis l'âge de saison on va
dans des stands de tir on est accompagné
par newzoo nos pères nos grands pères
voilà on multiplie on multiplie le
maniement d'armé lors du permis de
chasse effectivement on contrôle si on
sait bien se servir d'une arme entre
autres à fusil le casser des armées
l'armée tout ça est par ailleurs je
voudrais quand même bien trouver que
c'est que l'amalgamme sur l'alcool et
éventuellement les spéciales et et
discuter faire la chasse c'est désolant
bien
sûr c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans le
rapport donc si c'est écrit noir sur
blanc dans le rapport c'est bien qu'il
ya un souci
ben non mais c'est pas du tout souci je
veux dire regardez quand quand il ya des
accidents en état d'ébriété par exemple
quand quelqu'un conduit on demande pas
tous les gens qui montent dans leur
voiture de souffler dans le ballon vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
peut-être qu'une fois ou deux il ya eu
des gens qui ont été en état d'ébriété
et et le k2 malheureusement de morgane
que citer madame la personne n'était en
aide at état d'ébriété voyez ce que je
veux dire donc arrêtons ces amalgames
vous en supplie quoi c'est atroce quoi
alors je la parole n l
de revenir vers vous si vous êtes en
voiture et que vous faites arrêter par
la gendarmerie qui vous fait souffler
si vous êtes alcoolisées on vous retire
le permis de même vous allez
on va laisser parler hélène barbry vous
avez eu la parole on un jour leur
donnerait on ne le retire pas le permis
si vous chassez sous l'emprise de
l'alcool c'est parfaitement légal et par
rapport aux homicides dont vous parliez
il faut savoir qu'un homicide
involontaire commis en voiture et
sanctionner beaucoup plus sévèrement que
l'homicide involontaire commis à la
chasse et des suspensions de permis elle
102 5 10 ans et 10 ans et elles sont
très très faiblement
prononcée par les juges je voulais juste
vous dire un petit témoignage pour vous
montrer l'ampleur de la problématique de
ces suspensions et de 2,7 des péni
dépénalisation qu'il y a c'était en 2012
nicolas 12 ans fait du quad comme chaque
dimanche avec son père en seine maritime
il tombe sur un groupe de chasseurs et
s'arrête le chasseur leur demande vous
n'avez pas vu les pancartes il répond
qu'il n'en avait pas à l'entrée du
chemin la suite c'est le père du défunt
de l'enfant qui raconte au moment où
j'allais mettre en route le quad j'ai
entendu le coup de feu j'ai senti
nicolas s'écrouler sur mon dos le
chasseur 10 et maire de merde j'ai fait
le con j'ai vu le petit la tête pleine
de sens les chasseurs ont essayé de
faire les premiers soins c'était trop
tard fana citation l' expertise
balistique dira que le fusil était très
vieux que son cran de sécurité ne
fonctionnait pas que le chasseur n'avait
pas cassé son fusil 5il la vie respecté
aucune règle de sécurité et qu'est-ce
qu'il a eue ce monsieur il a une
suspension de cinq ans du permis de
chasse pour avoir tué un enfant de 12
ans en quad qu'il avait face à lui on
est vraiment dans une dans une problème
il a pas eu de prison ferme rien on est
vraiment dans une problème dans un
problème de sanctions hélas ce rapport
il propose en proposition numéro 10 de
développer des stages alternatif aux
poursuites pénales en cas de
comportements dangereux on est dans une
aile un engagement
deux des panneaux donc vous dites que
depuis 2012 en fait ça va de 2012 que
vous nous racontez ça n'a pas vraiment
changé on pourrait en citer là je vous
lis ce témoignage parce qu'il est
poignant mais on pourrait en citer et
quand j'entends que les accidents
diminue là aussi je suis désolé je suis
obligé de rebondir sur les chiffres je
pense qu'il manque d'un statitiques d'un
statisticien au sénat les chiffres sont
complètement fausses et ils sont biaisés
les calculs sont faux on ose comparer
les accidents de chasse à des accidents
de trampoline ou de marche nordique mais
un trampoline ou des chaussures de
marche
non pas pour finalité la mort de
quelqu'un en fait vous donne animal
on compare le nombre d'accidents de
chasse au nombre d'accidents de voiture
qui percute des animaux mais il ya 38
millions de véhicules qui circulent de
ville de voiture il ya un million de
chasseurs donc on ne peut pas comparer
ces chiffres là est vraiment c'est
incroyable de voir qu'ils ont travaillé
autant de mois sur un rapport et qui
rien n'est concret rien et fiable alors
vous avez l'un et l'autre
citer une autre une autre affaire qui
avait évidemment défrayé la chronique et
je vais vous proposer tout de suite de
voir un extrait extrait d'un
documentaire d'un reportage format long
réalisé par samia de sheer journalistes
de la rédaction de de public sénat c'est
justement l'histoire de morgane avec ça
sa compagne qui quitte à l'origine d'une
des pétitions elle témoigne dans ce
documentaire regarder
de décembre 2020 vert
16h50 17 heures donc en plein hiver
cette journée
c'était encore en confinement et morgane
est allé couper du bois dans ce bosquet
ici qui se trouve à une centaine de
mètres de sa maison
il avait un casque orange une
tronçonneuse est en fait
aux alentours de 16h50 17 heures il ya
un chasseur qui l'a pris pour un
sanglier et qui attire et qui l'a touché
au thorax
il a été il ya eu une tentative de
réanimation
et mais au final il est décédé quelques
minutes après
le lendemain il ya le procureur du lot
qui a dit que toutes les règles de
sécurité avaient été respectées
du coup on s'est dit mais comment
comment il peut y avoir
un
assassinat du d'un homme alors que des
règles de sécurité ont été respectées ça
veut dire que les règles ne sont pas du
tout suffisante donc ça c'est la sphère
le drame qui déclenche d'une certaine
façon là la pétition je propose à quand
un calme et de nous rejoindre tout de
suite quand un parce que ya donc ce
rapport et c'est un long processus qui a
précédé ce rapport avec cette forme de
démocratie participative qui a démarré
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs années on
peut le dire tout à fait thomas c'est au
moment où la france en fait lancé sa
première convention citoyenne celle
appelée vous sur le climat à l'automne
2010 9 que le sénat a mis en place cette
initiative
on sait que la chambre eu autant est
plutôt frileuses en matière de
démocratie participative
mais c'était un pas en fait dans cette
direction
annoncé par gérard larcher dans une
conférence de presse en septembre 2019
alors l'idée thomas c'est tout simple
n'importe quel citoyen peut publier son
idée de pétition sur le site du sénat
sanaa le point fr il faut ensuite réunir
cent mille signatures dans un délai
maximal de six mois si ce seuil est
atteint et cela a été le cas quatre fois
depuis que eh bien cette initiative a
été prise la conférence des présidents
du sénat est saisie il s'agit un de
l'organe du sénat qui organise le
travail parlementaire et alors cette
instance peut organiser une mission
flash une commission denquête ou encore
un débat dans l'hémicycle ans que vous
nous disiez 4 pétition ont atteint ce
seuil des cent mille signatures lesquels
en fait c'est vrai que cette initiative
elle a pris du temps à être connu du
grand public mais le rythme auquel les
pétitions sont signés et maintenant en
constante accélération est alors parmi
les quatre pétition sur le site du sénat
qui ont très bien marché il y en a trois
sur quatre qui sont consacrées au thème
de la chasse c'est dire comme ce sujet
et clivant et on l'entend dans vos
débats en plateau et comment ça mobilise
l'opinion est donc on pense donc à cette
première pétition autour de ce qui s'est
passé avec morgane et que vous évoquez
est lancée par ces deux jeunes femmes
qui avaient perdu donc cet ami dans un
accident de chasse c'est donc cette
initiative un qui a provoqué la mission
de contrôle qui a travaillé le février à
juillet dernier cas rendu son rapport
aujourd'hui en contre-feu le président
de la fédération nationale de la chasse
willy schraen il a également lancé sa
propre pétition qui a aussi atteint les
100 mille signatures alors 8 son idée
c'est de priver de subventions des ong
qui commettent des délits dans sa ligne
de mire ils visent des associations qui
commettent des actions d' entrave de
violence d'intrusion ou de dégradations
au nom de la cause animale et donc ça
c'est qu'effectivement quelque chose qui
a également réuni cent mille signatures
et puis là au mois de septembre nouvelle
pétition qui atteint ce seuil voilà là
l'interdiction dieu pour l'interaction
du déterrage de blaireaux une technique
de chasse jugées cruelles pas des
écologistes et plusieurs associations
pour voilà pour la cause est la cause
animale et de leur côté 1 les chasseurs
explique que cette population d'animaux
sains de blaireaux elle doit être
régulée dans certains départements elle
peut détruire la vigne ou endommagé les
voies ferrées donc on verra quelle suite
le sénat donne voilà cette dernière
pétition sur le blaireau un que vous
voyez à l'image nous on voit donc aussi
que l'initiative lancée en 2019 par le
sénat c'est au coeur d'une bataille de
cliquer acharnée entre pro et
anti-chasse comme à merci beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'éléments à sur lesquels
rebondir avec à nos invités dans ce
débat tancrède delà de la morinerie je
rappelle que directeur des rédactions de
du groupe rue world media et donc du
chasseur français c'est cette notion de
régulation expliquez nous le rôle des
chasseurs pourquoi c'est important et et
pourquoi aussi c'est souvent ce qui est
mis en avant par les fédérations les
associations de chasseurs
en fait c'est assez simple aujourd'hui
grâce aux efforts qui ont été faits
parce qu'on a mis en place qui est le
plan de chat c'est à dire que chaque
année il ya un certain nombre d'elle
mots qui sont attribués en fonction de
la densité les massifs forestiers par
exemple pour les chevreuils le cerf ou
sangliers et un certain nombre d'animaux
qui devraient prélever et entre autres
il ya une énorme problématique
aujourd'hui sur le sanglier en france
puisqu'il ya près d'un million 200
billets qui sont présidées par an et
malgré les efforts des chasseurs a
aujourd'hui les chasseurs chasse
quasiment 2 allez on va dire il commence
à chasser le sanglier en battue à partir
al'approche à partir de juin et en
battue à partir d'août jusqu'en février
parfois avec des prolongements jusqu'en
mars et il reste quand même dans plein
de territoires en france dès
surpopulation de sangliers qui viennent
manger dans les poubelles comme vous le
voyez leur désinformation des actualités
ou qui détériorent les living et puis
surtout qui détériorent très fortement
les cultures donc on a un problème c'est
qu'on n'arrive plus à venir à bout de
ces les populations gigantesque
maintenant de cendriers et en plus le
gros problème c'est que ce sont seuls
des chasseurs qui supporte les i ce
qu'on appelle les dégâts de grand gibier
c'est à dire que c'est lui fédération
des chasseurs ceux qui payent leur
permis qui paye entièrement les dégâts
de qui sont causés aux agriculteurs et
aux cultures chaque année il ya
certaines fédérations de chasseurs qui
n'arrivent plus à payer ce parce que ces
dégâts parce que c'est en millions
d'euros donc ça devient une vraie
problématique et je pense que c'est un
problème sociétal
ça veut dire comment on fait aujourd'hui
pour faire en sorte qu'elles mentent
sans lui j'accueille fabrique dans les
journalistes spécialistes des questions
d'environnement c'est moi pour morte est
ce vous n'y êtes pour rien c'est ce sont
les traces alors qu'ils ont joué leur
mauvais rôle aujourd'hui ça arrive ce
n'est pas bien grave je rappelle que
vous êtes journal spécialisé questions
d'environnement et auteur de la chasse
le vrai du faux aux éditions delachaux
et est signé seul et vous avez du coup
j'aime pas du tout dire du coup donc je
m'en veux de l'avoir de la voir glisser
dans une phrase vous avez eu encore plus
de temps pour lire le
leur âge genre et ses 30 propositions
finalement est-ce que vous êtes surpris
par ce rapport à ce que ces nac est
quand même une instance
des territoires de la ruralité pouvait
aller dans un autre sens d'après non
parce que c'est le sénat c'est sur un
temps long et c'est la ruralité face à
un parlement qui est plutôt sur un temps
court et l'urbanité donc le sénat le
senate défend l'image qu'il se fait de
la ruralité et l'image de la ruralité a
été approprié par la chasse parce que on
est impie de rapports de force et parce
que les chasseurs c'est une seule tête
willy schraen qui défend qui prétend
défendre la biodiversité les animaux
réguler les sangliers et représenter
c'est vrai c'est vrai que les chasseurs
sur les populations 200 milliers il ya
un rôle de régulateur qu'on peut pas
nier oui mais un rôle de réacteur qui
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne plus les
chasseurs sont en partie jeudi en
participant totalité responsable de la
situation des sangliers parce qu'il fut
un temps où les agréent nez il fut un
temps on les a nourris par ce qu'il
fallait il fallait qu'on puisse chasser
des sangles et parce qu'il n'y avait
plus de petites de deux petites proies
le comment vous dire le la
transformation du modèle agricole dans
les années 60 70 80 avec la biodiversité
a chuté et en gros caricaturalement on
chasse plus de perdrix donc on s'est mis
à chasser en baie de somme par exemple
des gibiers d'eau et puis on s'est mis à
chasser encore plus qu'avant du sanglier
puisqu'il n'en avaient pas assez il fut
un temps dans les années 70 où on les
nourrissait est arrivé là dessus le
changement climatique et favoriser les
portes et c'est donc aujourd'hui et plus
que les chasseurs fin n'y a pas que ya
aussi des chasseurs dit assez remonté
par exemple allouer nef les louvetiers
mais ils s'en sortent plus n'en compte
les chasseurs 10 on réguler cette
biodiversité
déséquilibré c'est faux et archi faux il
ne régule plus rien la situation lors a
complètement échappé à échapper à tout
le monde oui il nous manque dans ce
débat un sénateur ou une sénatrice pour
défendre le rapport sont des choses qui
arrivent au régime panique le rapport
était pardon mais je voudrais du coup
redonné la parole à tancrède delà de la
morinerie sur ce rôle de régulateur
parce que vous manifestez avec frédéric
dans l'est vous avez deux visions qui
sont pas là même qui sont pas les mêmes
expliquez-nous
alors en fait
notre journaliste qui vient d'arriver là
il a en partie raison mais c'est
toujours compliqué d'expliquer des
choses comme ça par exemple moi ce que
je trouve génial c'est grâce au plan de
chasse on voit plein de mouflons
chevreuils clown cercle 1 10 à 20 de
chamois partout on a on a plein de
grands gibiers partout il faut quand
même le dire c'est parce que c'est les
chasseurs qui s'en sont beaucoup occupé
aujourd'hui si encore des ti tetra des
grands et rahan france et parce que les
chasseurs ils vont couper les multis y
vont ils vont s'occuper justement des
milieux donc arrêtons tout le temps de
taper sur les chasseurs moi je suis un
écologiste mais vraiment je fais plein
de choses chez moi pour l'aménagement
des territoires et tout ça donc je vois
très bien tout ce que je fais ça profite
à l'ensemble de la faune et j'en suis le
premier premier à dire que c'est super
gt ornithologues avant d'être chasseur
vous voyez je peux pas je je suis
capable de partir avec tous les gens qui
se font sur votre plateau et je prendrai
grand plaisir à les emmener faire de
leurs mythologies pourquoi pas les
emmener à chasse mais dire
qu'aujourd'hui on régule plus rien et
qu'on s'en occupe a donc ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que on a un problème
d'abondance je veux dire sur sur le sens
de venir on n'a pas le même sur un peu
le même sur le sert de temps en temps
mais globalement l'intervention et la
bonne gestion des chasseurs c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de grands
gibiers en france si les gens quand ils
se baladent le week-end et ils le disent
tous on voit plus de grand gibier c'est
en partie parce que les chasseurs s'en
sont occupés et la réinfection pardon la
réfaction du petit gibier entre du
perdreau d'autre part et c'est un
problème de deux cultures mais de
culture agricole va c'est pas les
chasseurs il y a deux petits points que
j'aimerais relever par rapport à vos
propos la première chose c'est que
effectivement les chasseurs se plaignent
presque de ce devoir service public pour
faire respecter l'ordre public de devoir
tuer des sangliers qu'il préférerait
souvent faire de la chasse au petit
gibier mais la question se pose pourquoi
yat-il encore en france aujourd'hui 350
élevage de sangliers pourquoi il y a
encore 14 millions de faisans 5 millions
de paires degree qui sont élevées pour
être chassés si vraiment les chasseurs
vous en avez marre de chasser les
sangliers arrêté d'un élevé pour les
chasser la deuxième chose que je voulais
soulevé c'est pour rapporter les propos
de votre président willy schraen qui a
dit l'année passée à la radio rmc je
cite qui est s'est adressé à la
journaliste toi tu penses qu'on est là
pour réguler mais t'as pas compris t'as
pas compris que pour nous c'est une
passion ça pas compris qu'on parle du
plaisir dans l'acte de chasse et a pas
compris ça tu crois que nous on va
devenir effectivement les petites mains
de la régulation moi mon métier c'est
pas chasseur j'en ai rien à de
réguler à partir du moment où votre
porte parole à ces propos en public on
se pose question quant à la réalité de
la régulation et en suisse au canton de
genève la chasse est interdite il régule
autrement il n'y a pas d'accident mais
ça se passe très bien
bon jeu j'ai entendu squeeze mai
je reviens vers vous temps crée de la
monnaie on peut on peut réguler et ça
peut être aussi une passion c'est pas
antinomiques en fait ces deux choses
différentes c'est à dire que il ya la
passion de la chasse à dire l'acte de se
balader dans la nature avec un rapport
différent effectivement que d'autres
personnes quand on est dans la nature et
la régulation effectivement de ce ce que
voulait dire et de façon un peu
peut-être provocateur le président de la
fnc c'est que se retrouver tous les
dimanches où tous les toutes les
semaines roues on a comme consigne de
prélever des sangliers c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on a envie quoi vous
voyez comme moi je me retrouve temps en
temps dans des sociétés de chasse dans
le sud-ouest où on arrivait le matin et
10 voilà il y a encore des sangliers
dans les domaines alice il envoie les
chiens tout ça est le truc c'est tout ce
qui sort on essaie de en tirer le
maximum dont parfois délai de suite et
puisqu'aujourd'hui les consignes c'est
ça c'est que parfois sur certains
territoires faut même prélever délais
c'est-à-dire des femelles qui peuvent
être gestantes ou qui ont des ti
croyez-moi nous ça nous fait pas marrer
du tout pendant des années on rompt les
a épargnés justement pour permettre à
ces populations de se développer
aujourd'hui on en est essayé de de
prélever de réguler le maximum le
maximum de son billet est effectivement
disons que c'est un contexte qu'une
totalement haute c'est à dire comme
l'impression de mettre une casquette est
effectivement avoir une mission de
service public alors que c'est pas celle
que pour lesquels normalement on prend
un permis de chasse
allez-y terminée non c'est vrai c'est un
vrai débat ça veut dire que vous parliez
maddin du canton de genève et dieu sait
si un sujet qu'on a traitées dans nos
magazines quand vous dit que ça se passe
bien dans ça se passe pas très bien mon
papa s'est dit on va pas passer dix
minutes sur le canton de genève la vraie
question et je vais redonner à la parole
afghan et juste après c'est la question
évidemment de ce partage la de la nature
partage des espaces naturels et c'est
pas forcément simple pour les élus je
vous propose un autre extrait du
reportage de samia de sheer
donc long reportage qu'on a qu'on a
diffusé il ya quelques mois elle est
cette fois ci à l'ail et on est dans une
commune d'ille et vilaine et là aussi ça
commence par un drame un automobiliste a
été tué par une balle perdue puis
ensuite ya la question on y revient de
la prolifération des sangliers de la
réaction de la mère face à cet accident
mortel regardez bien donc ça compense
mans les sangliers sont de plus en plus
nombreux et ravage les terres des
agriculteurs
tout ça c'est des gars non mais on voit
bien que tout est arraché quoi il n'y
avait pas que un sanglier encore faire
pousser des gars là c'est des bandes de
sangliers qui viennent toutes les demies
régulièrement n'y a plus plus de la
moitié de la parfaite qui est touché
chaque année les sangliers abîme 8
hectares des terres de ce couple une
perte sèche de 5000 euros assez
difficile psychologiquement très
difficile quand vous allez pouvoir le
suivre
si vous avez papa mais normalement n'y a
pas de souci après l'accident dramatique
qui écoute et lévis un homme sur sa
commune la maire de lille a pris une
décision radicale
on a pris un arrêté sur la commune
interdisant toute action de chasse dans
les 150 mètres autour des habitations
obligeant
les chiens de chasse à être tenus en
laisse dans les 150 mètres autour des
habitations et interdisant le tir à la
carabine sur toute la commune la
réaction n'a pas manqué très vite les
chasseurs ont rangé leurs armes et
globalement la chasse c'est complètement
arrêté le vivant
parce que j'assure estimé qu'avec ces
restrictions ne pouvait plus chasser
d'accord ils vous ont fait une petite
fille petites mesures de rétorsion en
disant vous allez beaucoup trop loin et
donc ne chasse plus du tout et vous
allez voir ce que ça va ce que ça va
donner eu que les communes des environs
étaient chassés l'ail et n'était plus à
chasser
l'animal il est parfois donc en fait il
me revenait sur la commune se réfugier
dans les bois de l'ail est mené c'est
par une surpopulation de sangliers sur
sa commune
la mère a dû faire marche arrière élevés
sont arrêtés
c'est intéressant parce que on est là
sur la puissance locale or c'est aussi
un vrai maillage local c'est une vie
sociale la chasse faut jamais l'oublier
c'est une tradition il ya tout ça mais
aussi cette puissance divine des élus
locaux c'est pas simple quand on est élu
local de s'attaquer je mets des
guillemets aux chasseurs bah oui parce
que dans un village quand il ya même
plus de pauses plus de boucherie plus
rien plus d'associations sportives reste
que les chasseurs qui font vivre le
tissu social après les chasseurs dans
toutes les fées des jazz les fédés de
chasse conca genre d'enquêté pour ce
bouquin un président de fédé de chasse
m'avait dit c'est pas compliqué nous on
a le pouvoir d'aller voir tous les élus
de notre territoire quels qu'ils soient
en moins de 24 heures qu'ils ont un
pouvoir d'influencé
relativement important qui fait peur qui
fait peur aux élus locaux et qui peut
les dissuader de d'engager une action
contre le monde de la chasse qui encore
une fois se présente comme le seul
garant le seul héros de la ruralité
alors faut arrêter d'un côté de taper
sur les chasseurs en permanence ce qu'on
leur reproche seulement cette pâte
hypocrite comme nous c'est à dire que
vont tuer pour manger dans un monde une
société qui refuse tout même les
insultes qui refusent le sang étaient
ils le font très bien moi j'ai rien à
dire là-dessus mais en même temps les
chasseurs faut quand même qu'ils
comprennent que le monde a changé que
même la rural tu as changé qui a les
chasseurs traditionnels que sont les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs partent en
retraite dont il ya moins de ces
chasseurs traditionnels il ya plus de
néo ruraux il ya plus de jeunes qui en
ont rien à faire de la chasse avec du
coup les problèmes qu'il y aura demain
sur les sangliers c'est certain mais en
tout cas accordé un jour de semaine sans
chasse oui ce serait un pas en terme de
communication ce serait oui ce serait
bien même si d'autres pays européens
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ne font pas
au moins qu'il fasse ça et ça je pense
que ça faciliterait la ville tout le
monde et ça faciliterait la vie des
mères parce que c'est diminuerait les
tensions alors ça ne fait pas partie des
propositions de ce rapport du sénat la
proposition numéro 28 ne pas retenir
deux jours sans chasse au niveau
national et materis dé mettre en place
le cadre de dialogue qui permettra d
adaptation locale concertée entre les
acteurs du territoire puisqu'on parle de
la puissance mathieu dudule du lobby des
chasseurs vous avez voulu vous pencher
sur cette relation particulière avec le
président de la république voyez pas ce
que c'est beau comme une histoire
d'amour le 6 avril dernier modèle macron
alors en pleine campagne présidentielle
prenez sa plus belle plume pour écrire
une lettre à ulrichen dont on va parler
ici le tout puissant président de la
toute puissante fédération nationale des
chasseurs
durant les cinq années nous avons eu un
dialogue régulier franc et constructif
minaudait le candidat faux modeste dans
un genre de remerciement à peine voilée
parce que quelques semaines plus tôt le
même willy schraen lui avait appelé à
voter pour emmanuel macron et dès le
premier tour s'il vous plaît un
président qui mettra toute son énergie
pour répondre à nos demandes j'ai sa
parole il ne m'a jamais déçu by
manquerait plus que ça parce que depuis
l'élection de l'un des macros en 2017
les chasseurs n'ont jamais été aussi
bien traiter c'est une salve de cadeaux
qui s'est abattue sur les amoureux de la
gâchette de la part d'un président qui
se piquent par ailleurs d'être un
chantre de la biodiversité de dérogation
décret le président a mis dans le mille
à chaque fois rien que les dernières
l'exécutif n'a pas hésité à lancer par
exemple de grande consultation publique
sur le site de matignon pour contourner
des décisions du conseil d'état tenté de
contourner des décisions du conseil
d'état qui visait à restreint des
méthodes de chasse traditionnelle qui
serait ce que l'on conseil d'état
contraire au droit européen
l'exécutif a aussi raccourci les délais
entre la promulgation du calendrier
officielle de la chasse et l'ouverture
effective de la chasse histoire
dénoncent les associations de les
prendre de vitesse pour pas qu'elle ait
le temps de déposer des recours mais
c'est rien même à côté du tableau de
chasse financiers pourquoi la fédération
nationale des chasseurs n'a jamais été
aussi riche oui grâce à une série de
décisions qui aboutit à une augmentation
alors des aides de l'état calculé par
hugo en colère je crois une sociaux ou
représentés de 23000 % en cinq ans pour
faire simple il avoir eu la division par
deux du prix du permis de chasse de 400
à 200 euros c'est en fait c'est un coup
de pouce on pourrait dire ça rapporte
moins mais non en fait ça rapporte plus
parce qu'avant les chasseurs prenez
plutôt des permis de rêver auprès des
fédérations départementales et là ça a
rapporté à la fédération nationale
qu'elle est donc un permis moins cher
28 millions d'euros l'an dernier contre
11 millions auparavant donc c'est quand
même une petite butte assez incroyable
et des subventions publiques aussi qui
sont passés de 27 mille euros en 2017 à
ces trois millions en 2021 attention en
compensation de responsabilité qui était
autrefois la charge du préfet et qui
incombe aujourd'hui aux chasseurs s'est
pas non plus des subventions comme ça
pour n'importe quoi et puis une cerise
sur le gâteau qui est dénoncé par les
associations anti chasse et une éco
contribution de 10 euros par permis
quirky reversés pour financer des
projets de reconquête de la biodiversité
est là pour le coup les associations
disent que c'est des projets sont pas
assez précis on voit pas assez certaines
disent que c'est autant demander aux
communes marlboro de de financer les
campagnes anti tabac pourquoi tant de
gestes d'affection pourquoi tant de
gestes d'affection de la part du
président la république on pourrait dire
que sa terre natale la picardie est une
terre de chasseurs peut-être le poids de
l'histoire dans sa lettre aux chasseurs
emmanuel macron salué un attachement
séculaire à la ruralité ses traditions à
son environnement à ses paysages au fond
la chasse lui donne des racines d'une
certaine partie de la population lui
dénient par ailleurs et puis il pense
aussi que c'est un facteur
d'attractivité il l'avait dit par
exemple les chasses présidentielles pas
encore remise mais ça fait partie de
l'attractivité de la france est un peu
de tout ça sans doute mais aussi surtout
le gibier électorale qui l'intéressent
on parle d'un million de licenciés et en
rajoutant les familles et les amis qui
vont avec peut-être quatre millions de
personnes sur les estimations les plus
basses et ça ça vaut bien quelques
quelques cartouches dorées il ne restait
que quelques minutes dans dans ce débat
merci mathieu je voudrais qu'on parle de
cette cette idée d'un pour cent chastan
great delà de la morinerie est ce que
c'est c'est quelque chose dont vous
voulez absolument pas entendre parler ou
alors peut y avoir une discussion
comment vous positionner par rapport à
ça
déjà moi je représente pas les chasseurs
influent part je jouais en ami je suis
pas lié à la fédération nationale des
chasseurs mais ce que je sais c'est que
en fait le jour chantage qui existe déjà
dans plein de département il faut savoir
déjà que les forêts donc les forêts qui
sont gérés par l'office national des
forêts il n'y a pas de chasse le
week-end par exemple c'est ce que en
semaine il ya plein de départements moi
je suis par exemple normande ans dans la
manche il ya deux jours par semaine ou
en chasse pas donc ce que veut dire de
ce que je comprends les aménagements
dont parle dans le sénat c'est en faire
dans le terme d'homogénéité cd qui a
déjà vu un département il ya plein de
secteurs et yémen comme eux commune par
commune et où on peut pas chasser donc
je comprends bien pour des gens qui sont
contre la chasse qu'ils veulent il ya un
marqueur une espèce de journée sans
chasse mais c'est à dire qu'ils auraient
une journée son vtt il y aura une
journée je sais pas sans s'en voir on
est à cheval une journée sans pouvoir
ramasser les champignons que j'aime bien
mais en terme de jeu c'est que moi je
trouve ça un peu contraignant et puis
après il ya autre chose c'est que là on
parle puisque c'est un peu le sujet du
jour des phases de grand gibier mais il
ya des chasses à une ample apa londres
dans le sud ouest on chasse le migrateur
le migrateur il choisit pas les jours
vous voyez pour migrer donc imaginé une
immigration à jour qui soit à vendredi
la chasse interdite ça pourrait être un
peu dommage pour les gens qui comme dans
les palombières mais en tout cas sachez
que dans quasiment tous les départements
il ya déjà des journées où des lieux on
ne chasse pas sas et c'est partout
partout en france bah oui justement le
problème c'est que c'est un millefeuille
administratif on s'y perd demain je vais
en vacances dans le gers je veux aller
me balader avec mes enfants
dans la forêt je vais devoir aller
chercher sur internet si j'ai le droit
d'aller ce jour là dans cette forêt là
sur ce sentier là on est complètement
perdu plus de 60% des accidents de
chasse en lieu le dimanche dans le
rapport il est clairement proposé dans à
plusieurs reprises par exemple
proposition 19 de favoriser la prise
d'un arrêté interdisant l'accès aux
zones de chasse lorsque les conditions
de sécurité le justifie donc le rapport
propose d'interdire aux non chasseurs
l'accès à des forêts et nous ce qu'on en
est là pour la sécurité on n'est pas là
pour le grand gibier ou quoi on est là
parce que les chasseurs représentent un
million de citoyens français contre 67 à
peu près millions de citoyens non
chasseurs et on a notre liberté de
circulation notre liberté de jouir un
droit à un environnement sain qui est
complètement altérée pour l'activité de
loisir et éventuellement de régulation
de certains chasseurs donc c'est ça non
on demandait juste à ce qu'il y ait une
journée nationale pour qu' on n'est pas
avant 2 si on veut sortir spontanément
se balader en forêt on n'est pas à
chercher aussi on peut si on ne peut pas
qu'est ce qu'il en est et il ya des
mères qui pousse encore plus loin dans
la nièvre il ya un maire qui a pris un
arrêté récemment et qui oblige les non
chasseurs qui vont se balader à porter
des gilets jaunes et si vous ne portait
pas de gilet jaune vous avez une
contravention de 135 euros donc on est
complètement dans une inversion 1
millions de personnes détiennent le
pouvoir sur la nature à l'instant là et
pourtant si je voulais à les y aller il
faut damas par le nom mais la légère son
prix je connais bien il s'avère que
madame vous parliez d'année vous
promener en forêt que juste rappeler
quelque chose c'est que ça c'est un
droit chez supor rien mais en tant que
tout citoyen vous pouvez pas aller vous
promener partout vous voyez il ya la
forêt privée en france
la loi fait que si vous avez envie de
vous promener il ya déjà deux fait des
endroits qui vous sont interdits ou sans
l'accord du propriétaire donc ça déjà
quelle que soit la temporalité vous
pouvez pas y aller donc là on des forêts
publiques des forêts communales et celle
là c'est extrêmement simple le week-end
vous pouvez parfaitement aller vous
promener dans ces fois là puisque forêts
gérées par le hénaff ya match assez
compliqué que ça là même de façon plus
générale on parle des accidents on a
clos la saison de chasse l'année passée
avec une ordonnance de 25 ans qui s'est
fait huer par une mineure de 17 ans
passent comme france à 15 ans on peut
chasser et même à partir de ce nom à
partir de 15 ans peut pratiquer la
chasse accompagnée sans avoir passé un
examen sociaux n'est pas juste une
journée ou une demi-journée de formation
et on peut aller chasser à 15 ans on
peut tirer sans avoir permis de chasse
cru donc la saison de chasse est
clôturée par une ordonnance de 25 ans
tuée ça a ouvert ce week end qu est-ce
qui a eu il ya une deux noms chasseuse
qui se sont pris des plombs sur sur
leurs parties du corps et un chien tués
--dont et un automobiliste qui s'est
pris des plombs et le chien et la
randonneuse qui se sont pris des plans
étaient chez eux donc là on parle en
dehors de ça on parle même pas de
randonnée en bande de jours où on peut
être chez soi tranquille non sans
entendre on va terminer ce débat ce
pardon vous interdis se termine avec
deux éléments d'abord la réaction ça y
est c'est bien de tomber officielle en
cette fin d'après midi de la fédération
nationale de la chasse qui parle d'un
rapport choquant qui va coûter très cher
aux chasseurs qui vont - chassé et donc
ça va pénaliser les territoires ruraux
en fait il met l'accent sur le la
faisabilité de la mise en oeuvre de ces
mesures qui seraient trop coûteuse pour
les chasseurs évidemment c'est un début
d'un débat ça peut aller vers une
proposition de loi et va y avoir encore
des abonnements payants des discussions
bref on en est qu'au début vous allez
avoir le mot de la fin
en fait c'est un peu l'un d'eux j'ai un
peu l'impression qu'on parle d'un côté
d'une france éternelle
peut-être un peu rêver et de l'autre
voilà d'une france qui est en train de
bouger qui est ça craque un peu quoi oui
on aime bien les caricatures en france
et le manichéisme via la france qui
avance la france des villes et puis à la
france oui la france pauvre l'apprend la
france se figer sur ses valeurs
éternelles dont voilà le coup de chasse
fait par le petit fils avec son grand
père le dimanche matin c'est un peu
désuet c'est en train de disparaître
faut jamais oublier qu'à l'échelle
locale ya une excellente entente en
général entre les chasseurs et les
autres gardiens de la biodiversité bien
plus nombreux que sont les associations
de protection de la nature ou les cpu
etc etc qui travaillent souvent très
bien notamment sur les zones humides
sûrs et peu de zones humides notamment
en baie de somme qui serait encore
existant en france des zones humides
côtières cents l'action conjuguée des
naturalistes et des chasseurs ce que ce
dont convient d'ailleurs assez
régulièrement la lp au
sens les chasseurs et les naturalistes
qui aurait pas ce qu'on appelle les
trams écologique et trame verte et bleue
parce que les chasseurs avec les
naturalisme en particulier chasseurs qui
sont tout le temps dehors c'est eux qui
connaissent le moindre au bosquet le
moindre chemin creux et sans eux la
cartographie des zones à protéger sera
difficile à faire il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il ferait mieux de faire
quelques concessions notamment sur ce
jour de chasse et puis arrêtez cette
cuisine moi du terme cette saloperie
qu'aient le la chasse aux blaireaux
entre autres chasses dégueulasse parce
que s'ils ne le font pas ils vont perdre
le peu qui leur reste de soutien dans la
population urbaine et ça pourrait
précipiter leur faim demain on pourrait
très bien avoir un pays sans chasse et
on y perdrait quelque chose dans notre
culture dans notre anthropologie ce
serait quand même dommage wall a
beaucoup freiné je vous en prie même si
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
serré que j'appelle le titre de votre
livre c'est la chasse le ferai le vrai
du faux c'est publié aux éditions
delachaux et nier cela et puis tiens je
voudrais vous conseiller un roman
premier roman le titre c'est bichi des
signes et mona messine chant train de le
lire c'est un hasard absolue c'est un
jour de chasse vu par la biche qui
raconte vous laisse imaginer c'est très
très bien écrit merci encore à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau et en duplex est désolé pour ce
voile à ces difficultés ça arrive
rarement c'était pour ce soir mais on
s'en est sorti et je suis sûr que ce
débat vous a passionné